any of the lectures on the Internet
oh my goodness it does that work do you
feel that that's valuable how many of
you have deliberately blown off a class
knowing knowing that you could pick it
up later yeah you're here now yep that's
right
recidivists are are not here - all right
it's um
I think it's next week the new media
center is going to have a lunch for
faculty to talk about things like making
making Columbia content publicly
available and I think I'm going to be
kind of a poster child for that uh but I
must say I think that having stuff
publicly available is really good and my
sense is that if we had a dozen
professors at Columbia who had their
lectures available for free online that
would increase the number of applicants
to Columbia College because you know you
give away a little bit for free and then
they come back and they become high
price addicts and you know that can't be
bad for the university yeah
professor to get to get tenure I think
almost everyone would be resistant to
such a move the idea of shifting from
the from elite education delivered by
specialists to the the chosen few who
meet our standards to something that is
accessible or at least available to
everyone run so against the the history
of higher education and I think you'll
have a lot of resistance to the idea
nevertheless some universities MIT is
known to have a lot of material online
whether it's lectures or whether it is
just syllabi I don't know somebody told
me yale had some of this but i i kind of
doubt it
but in any case it's gratifying to know
that Nathan's
brilliance as a director of video
productions is not being entirely wasted
all right I was looking at a single
author world history from the 1990s by a
noted retired professor from Oxford and
I was looking at where Africa shows up
page 254 out of five hundred and eleven
pages you go halfway through the book
before you get anything about Africa
other than Out of Africa this is roma
sapiens began and it is a formidable
problem for for world history and it was
the what I was going to lecture on in
Tuesday so I'm going to give you a
somewhat truncated form of that and then
take up another area that is almost
totally but even more to collective let
us say and that is Island Southeast Asia
and the Pacific Islands so I want to
talk about two things today one of them
is Africa and the other is the history
of early seafaring so let's start with
Africa uh the argument made by the
learner I just mentioned was that the
his that history is based on written
documents there are no written documents
and therefore you have to wait a while
and he observes that things must have
happened in Africa peace some people
must have have experiences but that they
were inconsequential they did not
contribute to civilization and that down
to the present day Africa is primarily a
land that is acted upon by other people
than one that has its own trajectory now
he's a British author and of course the
Brits were accustomed to
you know ruling black Africa in a fairly
massive scale and he was old enough to
be over
pre decolonization generation in this
country you can't do that the African
American experience has essentially
eliminated the the cogent sea of
relegating Africa to a to completely
passive role it has enhanced however the
historic graphical problem of how do you
do it
given these the nature of the
documentation that is available the
quantity of documentation in terms of
written texts does not substantially
increase from decade to decade and no
one has come up with a you know
you know four thousand year early band -
you know translation of our life in East
Africa I mean it's you know it's not
there
however there's enormous change in to
other areas three other areas for other
areas one of them is archaeology what is
dug up a second one is climatology
how has Africa changed and how does that
relate to the other things a third is a
imagery that is to say for people who
did not leave written text they
nevertheless left an enormous corpus of
of pictures some engravings some
paintings and so forth and the quantity
of those increases with time as people
travel more broadly and then I guess the
the fourth area would be you know in
things like linguistics and other things
that might pertain to specific cultural
elements
if you go to the climatology what you
find is that the coming out of the last
ice age in other words going back to
about 12,000 BC BCE you you had a a
warmer and wetter world as those is very
obvious if you look up at global
geography there are bands of wind
direction and precipitation
both north and south of the Equator and
those bands can be a wider or narrower
during the ice ages the Sahara Desert
extended much farther south than does
now so when you go into areas of
sub-saharan Africa in what's known as
the Sahel area which is the savanna land
that is just south of the Sahara Desert
Sahel is the Arabic word for a Seacoast
so it's really the coast of the southern
coast of the Sahara you get a number of
dateable periods of what are considered
fossil sand dunes places that were once
sand and then became colonized by trees
or other vegetation the the dune became
immobilized you had an accumulation of
soil from the from the vegetable
detritus of what was growing there and
it becomes land that you can only
discover was once desert through through
excavation so one time the the Sahara
was much farther to the south and that
coincided with having vast quantities of
the world's freshwater Thai
and glaciers that extended down to you
know Wisconsin or down to to northern
Europe and the glaciation pushed weather
bands farther south when you had a
improvement and a warming of the climate
those weather bands shifted further to
the north so that not only did you see a
regression of the glaciers in Europe but
the most southerly extensions of the
Sahara became grassland and then
extended in well into what is now the
Sahara this was sometimes have strived
as as the monsoons the seasonal rainy
weather going up into the Sahara rather
than being strictly something that
happens around the fringes of the Indian
Ocean from East Africa across to
Indonesia but in any case you had a a
wet Sahara I don't know if the slides
are available or not but okay but you
will see in the slides that I put on of
the Sahara Desert that you can fly over
the Sahara and you can see not just
river valleys but deep gorges that were
once full of of very substantial rivers
and you can see where they flow together
you can see where there were waterfalls
that this was a heavily watered area at
some time
the
therapy for the south
yes the the separation in the north
between the Sahara and the and North
Africa is marked by a very very dramatic
escarpment in other words you you come
in from the Mediterranean say in Algeria
and you you know it's a very narrow
coastal plain you go up the mountains
and these are the Atlas Mountains very
high very rugged it's the reason you
don't have much in the way of good
Seacoast west of Tunisia you climb the
mountains the mountains are heavily
heavily forested they once had lots of
wild animals for the exhibits in Rome
once you get over the mountains you
don't go down very far because the next
layer is a plateau region known as the
TEL and that is a flat grassy plateau
that extends really from the Moroccan
border in the West to to Western Tunisia
and the East and that was the heartland
of Roman North Africa that was where
they grew the wheat that was exported to
Rome it was dry and you have very
extensive Roman waterworks for
conserving water and reservoirs and
things of that sort but it was it was
agriculturally productive then you go
then you have a range of hills on the
southern edge of the towel you go over
the hills and then you have a quite a
steep descent and then you're in the
sand and if so it's a very dramatic
shift going into the Sahara from from
the north and there's a band of oases
going across the northern Sahara let's
say if we're talking about coming from
the Mediterranean you go up the
Mountains you go down to the tail go up
a little bit and now you're down in the
Sahara and the Oasis that you have here
are fed by groundwater that comes from
this area so you'll sometimes you'll see
in cannot formation where you can
actually see an underground canal more
likely a subsurface water that is tapped
by by artesian wells or dug wells in in
dry river valleys so there's a band of
OS e's across the northern Sahara they
are almost completely discontinuous
culturally and technologically and
historically from the oases that you
have in the central Sahara so you keep
on going across the Sahara and you get
to high mountains you get past the high
mountains and you're still in the Sahara
until it very very very gradually Peters
out on the southern edge so it's a
southern edge that's the variable and
indeed when you look at the French
geographers who wrote about the Sahara
they had a hard time defining when they
would find the Sahara and they finally
decided on one particular weed they said
where this weed begins the Sahara ends
because it was a it was just flat
country the blended from from complete
desert into some vegetation and they had
to pick a somewhat arbitrary marker so
the the southern extent is a variable
the northern extent some seems to be
seems to be less so so when you see rock
art you find rock art up here in the
Atlas Mountains you may find it here in
the tell but he don't find any rock art
in the northern a of Oasis they they
were not they did not benefit from this
monsoon phenomenon
that affected the southern Sahara and in
particular affected these mountainous
areas in the central Sahara so you have
us a sequence of mountainous areas that
go from from western Sudan across Chad
across Nazaire and southern Algeria and
then across Mauritania and Mali to some
extent and this hilum sequence of areas
is the heartland of the Saharan rock art
so the rock art of the Sahara is
essentially from here south and from
here north you don't get much of
anything presumably this has a
reflection in the human population that
is to say that when the Sahara was wet
the likelihood is that the central
Sahara was was populated and the
southern Sahara and that as desiccation
occurred people moved south rather than
north because the people you know this
area up here doesn't appear to have
gotten as much rainfall as the area
further to the south
so in this wetter period for a long time
all you had were a rock art and almost
no dateable archaeology now that is
beginning to change and and really I
think one of the things you have to keep
in mind you're something I mentioned in
earlier lecture that you know
archaeology really starts where it's
easiest you know where there's a
Starbucks and you come there no trees on
the ground and the mound is really
obvious and you
just go and dig it up and send it off to
the British Museum
but in hard areas this is where
archaeologists today are really making
my important work particularly in the
Americas and in Southeast Asia and to
some degree in Africa so now we have
some archaeology and it reveals things
that are quite suggestive in
northwestern Sudan about 80 miles west
of the Nile River you figure the the
green belt of a Nile River stretches
only well say less than a mile west of
the river in other words if you're dying
about 80 miles west of the Nile your
deep desert there is a place called
nebka Playa Playa simply meaning a
dried-up lakebed and nebka Playa has
yielded a really suggestive evidence
that has not yet been integrated into
into world history narratives one thing
that is yielded is a stone circle that
is about 2,000 years earlier than
Stonehenge and but that like Stonehenge
and numerous other stone circles and
structures around the world this one
appears to be oriented
according to astronomical observations
in other words you have a circle of
stones
and there are some stones that are
marked so now this will be due north
this will be due south this will be the
angle of the Sun at the time of the of
the solstice in other words it's not
been proven that that this or any other
of these early sites is based truly on
astronomical observation but it is so
consistent to find alignments that
accord with astronomical observation
that it's become a fairly general
generally accepted evidence that people
from outer space uh know that that that
there was a concern for astronomy or for
viewing the heavens that goes back a
very long way now here of course it's
interesting because it goes it's pre its
pre-agricultural so the people who say
oh once you start growing crops you'll
have to keep track of the seasons
because you can't really figure out what
comes after fall maybe it's summer again
and get spring no you know it it isn't
something as simple-minded as keeping
track of the seasons but rather
something else is animating this sort of
thing probably in my view something
closer to the notion of the macrocosm
microcosm philosophical interactions
that are so common in later cultures but
it could be something more more
practical now one of the interesting
things about this stone circle which was
just hit on a few years ago by actually
more than a few years ago by some guys
who were traveling through the Sahara
and almost literally ran into it is that
it's not like Stonehenge it's not big
stones it's smaller stones it's four
metres across twelve feet now from here
to here you've got the stone circle the
stones are light enough like the biggest
ones would be like 200 pounds to have
been brought in by
you know two or three people this would
have been before any animals adapted to
carrying burdens were available so this
was it wasn't a big social project that
lasted for years and consumed a
tremendous amount of of activity nor was
it the earliest thing at nub de playa
this stone circle is dated to around
5,000 BC which puts it close to 2,000
years before the earliest Egyptian
dynasties but the site appears to go
back to more like 7,000 BC and the site
is full of cattle bones initially simply
lots of cattle bones but by the time you
get to the later period of the site is a
site that's abandoned by forums say
around 4000 BC by the time you get to
the later ones you have cattle bones
being buried in stone chambers
you also have stone wells that are being
dug apparently in response to
diminishing rainfall or diminishing
water resources efforts to to adapt to a
changing climate and but by 4000 BC it's
sort of game over mm to Playa because
there isn't enough water to to replenish
the lake and they can no longer reach
sufficient water through wells now 4000
BC comes to the end of dead do plyo what
else happened in 4000 BC that's the end
of Old Europe very likely for the same
cause in other words what you're looking
at here is a climatological shift that
is drying up the Sahara
and it is turning colder in southern
Europe so the archaeologists are
guessing that the end of Old Europe
circa 4000 BC Oh plus or minus a bit has
to do at least in part with a cooling of
the climate there that makes it less
salubrious
and certainly the drawing up of Sahara
corresponds to that that you have a
cooling of the climate that pushes that
that dry band that had been pushed north
by the period of warmth so it was in the
northern Sahara only that's pushing it
farther south and the Sahara dries up so
the guest thing is that you have a
cattle rearing culture that is there in
by 7000 BC I'm not saying civilization
interesting a culture the number of
bones and indicates that this was a
significant Enterprise and as does the
evidence of ceremonial use of the bones
but the animals themselves do not show
the signs of domestication that you find
elsewhere what are the primary signs of
cattle domestication ok they come up and
they lick your hand but beyond something
like that one of the most important
signs is that they is that they diminish
in size almost everywhere you have
cattle in particular domestication is
associated with the reduction in size
and there is a generalized guess of the
reduction in size is not something that
is selected for I can't say everybody
agrees with this but it's not so much
something that is selected for as a
product of a
reduce nutrition that when you have a
grain farming society that is keeping
cattle as domestic animals additionally
for meat and eventually for milk they're
not feeding them as abundantly as they
would be feed as the wild cattle would
feed in on their own and of course the
same thing with the people the people
begin to develop problems of health
having to do with the grain diet so when
you find that the that the phenotype of
the cattle in nepto Playa is wild then
what to mean what you're looking at is
not an absence of domestication so much
as an absence of the limited feeding
that comes from a grain economy where
the animals are dependent upon what they
are what they're being fed now what this
points to is reinforcement of a theory
that's been around for some time and has
lacked really conclusive evidence and
that is the theory that cattle were
domesticated in Africa separately from
being domesticated in the Middle East so
in other words you go to 7,000 BC where
you have abundant camel capital remains
at nebka Playa
at the same time 7,000 BC as the
earliest proto urban community in the
Middle East that has a a cattle cult at
catalhoyuk and Turkey so in Turkey we
can see a cattle being you know exciting
a certain kind of reverence you'll have
rooms that will have the
the crania of cattle embedded in the
walls or the horn sticking out and this
is we believe where the practice of
having sort of extreme games jumping on
and off of horned cattle began but we
don't know and the bones make it clear
that that's very early in the period of
cattle domestication
there's no plausible connection between
central Turkey and northwest Sudan circa
7000 BC so you have the likelihood that
you have two different domestication
events one in the north and one farther
in the south now at roughly the same
time there is a site in in western libya
the name of which now slips my mind that
has fairly recently been excavated and
it reveals very very thick accumulations
of dung from Barbary sheep this is the
Barbary sheep is a wild animal of North
Africa that the northern the Atlas
Mountains in the northern part of the
Sahara it has never been a domestic
animal when you do get a rock art in the
Atlas Mountains in the north one of the
frequent motifs is a picture of a
Barbary sheep with the horns up and a
circle of the Sun between the horns so
it appears to have been an animal that
commanded a certain reverence and the
archaeological conjecture at this point
is that the accumulation of dung that
you have at this site in western libya
in the sahara desert is because they
were keeping the Sheep penned up and the
an animal that never became domestic
and this of course is one of the things
that is extremely awkward about most
theories of domestication that they
assume that that certain animals are
susceptible of domestication and others
are not and that humans early on
discovered which subsets could be used
and that sort of made domestication a
closed event of the know of the early
millennia BC this is Jared Diamond's
proposal but he's picking it up from a
number of other people what this
indicates is that you had a local wild
animal that was being penned up for
protracted periods of time or else you
wouldn't have gotten the degree of
accumulation of dung you have an animal
that we see in images as having some
sort of ritual attraction but it never
becomes domestic so then you have this
question of is there something about the
indigenous populations of the Sahara
Desert with their relationship to
animals that is fundamentally different
from the relationship of animals that
you find in the grain growing Middle
East where you have sheep and goats and
cattle cattle in a somewhat different
formation and different from what you
have in Central Asia where you have
people who know about horses to up
camels and farther north reindeer if so
then there's a question is whether
African history should start with Egypt
which is the extension into Africa of
the Middle Eastern complex or whether it
should be following the history of this
indigenous African pattern and if you
think in those terms then you say well
what happens to this cattle culture
that existed at one time and came to an
end if not at 4000 BC at least l
starting around that time with the
change in the climate the the rock art
that you have here is full of pictures
of cattle herding the pictures that I
had slides of were ones taken from a
book by on payload not envelope avi load
on the called the search for the Tassili
frescoes but it's very easy to go to
Google Images and get any number of of
good color photographs of cattle herding
in the in the rock art of the Sahara
Desert
there is an assumption by some african
historians that as the sahara became
drier and drier from say 4000 bc on that
some people may have moved into the nile
valley and become contributors to the
culture that develops in egypt farther
to the north but that others are likely
to have moved directly south and become
the progenitors of cultures that stretch
across sub-saharan Africa from Senegal
to to Somalia in other words you it's
you could have a chapter in world
history book that dealt with the
synchronicity of Saharan Africa and Old
Europe that would all be pre
civilizational but you'd have abundant
archaeological evidence and image
evidence for both areas and you would
end up putting Africa giving Africa
priority in this history because you
would have your chapter on Africa before
you get to those bloody river valleys
a very attractive proposition but where
how far can you go with them well then
you have to ask if you have a cattle
culture is it necessary that a cattle
culture move in the direction of plowing
and wheeled vehicles well no the African
one does not in order to connect the
cattle culture of Africa with a cattle
cultural Middle East you have to assume
that once the cattle got Africa if they
had already been harnessed for plowing
or pulling vehicles that people forgot
how to do it of course that would fit in
with a good colonial mentality but the
likelihood is that that these things
never occurred if fat cattle culture
what did occur in that cattle culture
well there is because of the nature of
the evidence it has a lot to do with
images one thing is is clearly has to do
with with ritual the people who have
excavated nebka Playa maintained that
the cattle cult there is very likely a
progenitor of the cult of hathor in
ancient Egyptian civilization Hathor is
portrayed as a cow a maternal a female
with cows horns and with a big circle
for the Sun between the horns analogous
to the circle for the Sun that appears
between the horns of sheep in images
from northern Sahara this is different
from the cult of of Mo in raw which is
symbolized by a bull but the bull and
the cow cults while separate are
obviously
complimentary to some respect and
because of my own obsessions I would
argue that the the bull and the and the
donkey that become such a fixation for
the ancient Egyptians represent a
pathological fascination with big
penises and that and that the Africans
had the wit not to do that but in any
case there's a ritual thing and it shows
up in another area which is odd and that
is the color patterns for domestic
animals of almost any species you have a
variety of color patterns and those
color patterns are associated with
selected breeding you know like you you
can look easily look up color patterns
for horses and find out that there are
you know just four or five different
sets of of genes that will affect the
color in different ways and if you mix
them in such in such a fashion
according to Mendel's laws you'll end up
with the Palomino or a Pinto or a white
horse or a black horse or whatever you
have but what you find in sub-saharan
Africa down to the present day
and what shows up in the in the earliest
images from Sahara Desert is a
particular fascination with with
splotchy black and white or brown and
white color patterns so it's the only
place in the world I know of where you
can get Pinto donkeys or Pinto camels
lots of Pinto cattle and hair sheep you
know sheep in the wild don't have wool
wool is something that arises with
domestication and is selected for so the
guard hairs
become less and less important and the
undercoat of wool becomes more important
not a good thing in the tropics so in
Africa the domestic in sub-saharan
Africa the domestic breeds of sheep are
mostly hair sheep they have no wool and
are often hard to distinguish from goats
but they have a curious color patterns
there's there's one fascinating breed
that is exactly 50% white front half is
white the black half a back half is
black just like it was sawn down the
middle you also have a fascination with
the shape of horns horns are can be
deformed in young animals and shaped in
a certain direction of the famous Oh
famous here half a dozen domestication
specialists who have heard of it but the
the the the Unicorn goat of Pakistan
which is a goat with only one horn is an
artificial creation where you take the
horn buds of a young animal and you push
them together so they grow together and
you end up with a unicorn go but in
Africa you get a sub-saharan Africa not
in the north you get a group of
peculiarities with horns
for example breeds No
where's your your cow
bulb horns certain breeds are chosen for
that you have others that are chosen to
horns that go forward this led to
Herodotus writing in discussing Libya
and the desert peoples of Libya he says
that is where they have the backward
grazing cattle says that when the cattle
put their head down to graze if they
walk forward their horns go into the
sand and therefore they have to graze
while walking backwards now that is not
true but it does demonstrate that there
was a special horn deformation in the
Sahara that the Greeks were totally
unfamiliar with but does show up in the
art and the rock art so we're dealing
with with an investigation pattern that
doesn't have the same set of sort of
economic utilities as the ones in the
north but has another set of affective
utilities having to do with ritual and
presumably an imputation of value that
is to say you you know among hurting
people's having live animals means you
are wealthy as opposed to among ranchers
we're selling dead animals proves that
you are wealthy so this is a is a form
of accumulation of property I think it
would be highly desirable to rewrite
world history from the premise that
property begins with animals instead of
with land or possibly it begins with
water but there simply weren't that many
people in the world there was lots of
land and land after all when it comes
it's dirt you know
this dirt is much like that dirt but
water can be a something that you own or
at least the means of getting the water
and animals are something that you own
so you have a culture that has wealth it
has property it has a spiritual
orientation it has an astronomical
interest and it moves from the Sahara
Desert into sub-saharan Africa where it
has a number of manifestations now those
manifestations are ones that in some
respects are associated with the
so-called Neolithic Revolution
for example pottery sub-saharan Africa
and the Sahel belt has pottery before
the Middle East does but it doesn't have
grain agriculture so I'm getting out
here is the idea that the Neolithic
fixation on grain agriculture emanates
fundamentally from the cultural
background of of historians of
euro-american background and precludes
thinking of another way to go and that
the Africans moved in a very different
way now the clincher in terms of their
difference has to do with a economic
utility that emerges in both the north
and the south but emerges differently
and this is the consumption of milk I've
mentioned this before that adult mammals
do not have the capacity in most cases
to digest milk at least beyond what
you'd put in your tea or on your
breakfast cereal and that what this what
happens is you get a phenomenon known as
lactase persistence
Oh
that is the lactase enzyme that digests
milk and which is present in all young
mammals normally disappears but it
persists if you have certain genetic
changes that that favor lactase
persistence for Europe and Asia there
appears to be one genetic change that
yields lactase persistence and it
appears to how to begin in North West
Europe as say Scandinavia Denmark areas
like that that was where you the highest
percentage of people who can digest milk
as you go farther south into southern
Europe it'll drop from like 95 percent
to 50 percent or less as you go east it
will drop my guess is that the one thing
about Northwest Europe is that before
the development of lactase persistence
there wasn't anybody living there this
was a recently glaciated miserable area
and therefore you didn't have a mixing
of a new hurting culture with an older
culture that was well established as you
would have had in the Middle East or in
China or in Central Asia and that that
might be why it appears to be so
concentrate in that area but in any case
that genetic change that appears in in
Europe and Asia never occurs in Africa
instead you have at least three and
probably four or more separate genetic
changes that arise in different parts of
Africa that produce lactase persistence
no this is three or four or more the
highest concentrations of those that
have been studied are in East Africa in
Kenya Tanzania areas like that but you
have other other changes in other areas
in other words what it looks like is
that a population that bred cattle moved
from the Sahara into sub-saharan Africa
and developed milk use at different
periods in different areas and adapted
genetically to facilitate that milk
consumption separately in different
areas whereas what you have in the north
indicates a one-time-only rise of milk
use somewhere probably in the Middle
East that spreads into other areas so in
other words the cattle culture of Africa
appears to be a lot more complex than
the cattle culture of Europe and Asia
but it appears to be a one that became
accustomed to the drinking of milk which
made the animal herds a great economic
value and this spread of cattle culture
then becomes a question to be confronted
with other evidence having to do with
the origins of sophisticated cultural
traits in sub-saharan Africa the spread
of the Bantu languages the the
development of iron smelting which
appears to be quite separate from the
Middle East so and so on and they're
written about in the chapter of the
you've read but what I'm trying to
suggest here is that if you talked about
old Europe
and and Saharan Africa together you
would be starting on an out in a very
different foot from the one you'd be
starting out on if you start with River
Valley civilizations and growing of
grain and I think that that would be of
great benefit both to the history of
Africa because it would grant it a
measure of autonomy whereas so often it
is seen as simply a derivative or worse
you know area of cultural development
and it would help to bring the the
hubris of the bread eaters under control
you know down with the bread eaters all
right so that's what I wanted to talk
about on on Tuesday
now I lecture for today is on a
completely different subject but it goes
back to something I have talked about
and that is the notion of energy
profiles what you find very commonly and
people who deign to talk about energy at
all is that animal and human power were
the only sources of energy for thousands
of years until you know James Watt
invented the steam engine or whatever
you want
you know until modern US came came about
of course this is you know one aspect of
this is that that wind power is
something that's discovered late the
windmills of Holland or the wind farms
we have now that using the wind is late
of course using the wind is not late if
you are on the water using the wind is
early but presumably when people started
to float around they didn't use the wind
they had paddle
or sticks or they pulled on the bushes
along the shore or they did something
else because there's nothing
particularly obvious about a sail the
the the older tradition of sail history
is marred by a assumption of diffusion
ISM that is to say the assumption is
that the sail was invented by Roger the
sail maker in Egypt in no 3000 BC and
all the sails in the world spread from
the Nile River and indeed those are our
earliest images and if you insist on on
rigid documentation then you say okay
well that's our earliest images and so
the later images must in influence from
there though how exactly those Egyptian
sails got to Indonesia is kind of left
opaque so I think that it's it's better
to make an assumption about the the
multifocal genesis of sailing rather
than assuming that there is one sail
idea that spreads though the literature
favours the idea of the one there's also
the question of you know what is a sail
made of say old sails made out of cloth
yeah well what about you don't have
cloth or what if your loom produces a
cloth that is 2 inches wide and 2 feet
long and you're going to sew together
all those so it's more likely it seems
that sails originally were made on a mat
that came from a plating of of Russia's
or Reed's into a map so that any place
that had ill Reed's or palm fronds or
something like that that could be turned
into strips and then woven together
would be a plausible place where you'd
have sails and then of course ties
sailing into the history of basketry
history of basketry is not very well
originally because it doesn't leave much
in the way of remains but there is a
argument that I think is not an oblong
sound one that that pottery may begin
with basketry yeah the problem with the
basket is that if you put it on a fire
it burns up but that's that's pretty
obvious so and yet you want to cook
something because chewing up you know
raw wheat grains grinds your teeth down
and dental care was poor so you want to
cook it you'd want to make this stuff
soft so how do you do it when you don't
have anything you can put on the fire
the idea was that you take a basket you
line the basket with something that will
be that will make it watertight like
clay and then you put in water and you
know some barley so wild onions maybe a
little tarragon or mant or something and
you take really really hot stones from
the fire and you drop them in to the
water and so you boil the stuff from the
inside out instead of putting it on the
fire because you can't put in the fire
you burn up the basket and the idea that
arise from that is supposing you
particularly after you discover that
that those hot stones make the clay
inside the basket real hard then you
think well why don't we take away the
basket and simply use the real hard clay
and then we have something that we can
put on the fire
that's one possibility but the thing is
that plating things appears to be
extremely old it doesn't depend on on
growing any particular plant or having
any particular tool it's just a way of
getting an expanse of something covered
that ways left that an animal skin so
plated maps were probably the first
sales the Egyptian ones the Egyptians
would have amassed
and they would have a square sail
typically wider than it is tall and they
would have a yard at the top in the yard
at the bottom and they would use it on
the Nile River but also in the Red Sea
and between say 3,000 BC and 1000 BC
this was the type of sail they used
after which they got rid of this yard on
the bottom and to say that the cross
beam and they simply have a cloth that
hung down and they could tie up tie it
down that lightens the whole whole
vessel so this is a square sail
tradition the squares tale tradition is
one of the important traditions and
sailing but it has very little to do
with most of the world sails the the
sails that you get in the Indian Ocean
and eastward seem to come from a
different concept and this was the idea
that
you would have a vessel and you had two
sticks like that and you would tie of a
square of matting you tie it across here
would hang down and then you would tie
one end to the front one in the back so
it was a a fore-and-aft sail with two
rather slender sticks that are called
spritz those is called a a double sprit
tight sail it is light it is
comparatively easy to make in its most
primitive form it can be found in
several places around the Indian Ocean
most notably because of the geographical
features on the island of Madagascar on
the western side of the Indian Ocean and
yet every indication is that it
originated in Indonesia on the eastern
side of the Indian Ocean so in other
words this appears to be a sail that
didn't go up and down the Nile River but
rather went all the way across the
Indian Ocean leaving traces here and
there that gets into the question of
dating because the island of Madagascar
which is now the Malagasy Republic and
speaks a language known as Malagasy that
language is an Indonesian language even
though the island is located very near
the east coast of Africa current
thinking is that the island was
uninhabited before people from Indonesia
got there that is to say that the
sailing vessels that brought them were
the first sailing vessels that were
available to people living in Eastern
Africa there is a guess that the
Indonesians probably settled on the
African
host but did not form a persistent
population and were eventually absorbed
by the indigenous peoples of the African
continent but that on the island of
Madagascar they were on their own and
they continued out of the present-day
when did this happen there is a guest
that you had a venue is a two-phase
development one phase let's say a round
or somewhat before 500 AD and another
one maybe a 500 years later around a
thousand AD how is this chronology
established when we don't actually have
any any really dateable remains on this
well as I said linguistics is part of
this Malagasy language is an Indonesian
language and it has 35 loanwords from
Sanskrit the other Indonesian languages
like Java knees and bahasa indonesia the
sort of general language or a chinese no
bukas other languages indonesia have
lots of Sanskrit words and the island of
bali is a hindu island in the middle of
indonesia the reason being that at some
point the Indian culture reached
Southeast Asia and had a massive impact
so that you had temples some of which
survived you had kingdoms you had rulers
with sanskrit names newid lots and lots
of sanskrit words but apparently the
speaker's of Malagasy left just as the
Indians were getting off the boat no
they just stayed around long enough to
pick up 35 words and then it was you
know sayonara Sumatra and they were off
off to Africa
that's the reason you get a you know
this ballpark dating of 580 because the
earliest Kingdom we know about for
Southeast Asia the Kingdom of Shri
Vijaya is around that time and that
seems to be when Indian culture is
really getting going in Indonesia so in
other words the the people who sell
Madagascar
we're in Indonesia until the Indians
began coming and then they left although
presumably there's a whole series of
migrations adding population to to the
Madagascar population so that gives you
a timeframe for this double sprit sail
development it's somewhere oh let's say
beginning of the Common Era or perhaps a
bit earlier now I know I my plan was to
give you a remarkable series of really
bad drawings to show you how it evolves
because there's a it's an interesting
evolution where you you know you can
have your spritz like this and then the
setting the square sail so let's just
have the sail be triangular and have it
fit between the spritz and now this is a
problem because it means that the
fullest force of the wind is up here and
you're down here so your boat is tippy
so then then they say well supposing we
tipped it so we have the spritz like
this with a triangular sail and that way
we lower the the center of force come
from the wind and that was okay except
how do you keep these spritz in this
position so then they have the idea well
let's let's really flatten it out and
make it like that and that put a kind of
a post in here with a cup device on it
to hold the sprit in place and that
becomes the mast these spritz are not
considered masts they're too light and
flexible to really qualify as mass so
now you're getting a design that's very
similar to the lateen sail of the later
Mediterranean and western Indian Ocean I
can give you anyone who wants a
reference to a a detailed article called
Eastern sail affinities if you want to
pursue this further but the point that
the author makes is that Indonesia
appears to be the the the sort of seabed
of most of the sail developments of the
Indian Ocean but in particular of the
Pacific and that you can find all the
way from Hawaii down to down to Samoa
and New Zealand you can find relations
between the sails that you can trace
back in design to the sprit sails that
evolved in Indonesia then they're a
little bit different for the Melanesians
as opposed to the Polynesians but you
know there are maps that sort of give
you the details about this but the point
is that the the sprit sails
were really effective for ocean ocean
transport now another noted feature that
probably preceded the sails in the East
was the use of outriggers you can have
outriggers on one side or out rigged
is on two sides and outriggers gives
stability to a to a boat and when you're
off in the ocean that stability may seem
to be particularly valuable if you are
rowing if you if you have a sailing
canoe with either a say double hug
catamaran double hulled catamaran or a
single or double outrigger it gives
stability as people are paddling the
craft once you put up a sail you have
something of a problem because the sail
causes the boat to to to to keel over as
the wind pushes it in this direction and
that risks putting your outrigger
underwater which then pulls the whole
boat down I mean it's terribly
destructive so you don't find sailing
canoes with double outriggers because
then they're in a mess now you can
counteract that if you start to heal in
one direction you can have everyone sort
of run out on the other side and shift
their weight and so forth and so on but
the you have these two different
traditions one that really seems to
arise from from manpower using paddles
and another related to to the use of of
sails and these things combined in this
whole series of boat designs that you
have in the East now the furthest
extension of these of this spritsail
development and use of catamaran type
vessels appears to be in a pre-columbian
development of sailboats in South
America these are both along the coast
off the coast of Peru and off the coast
of Brazil similar designs that were
there when the Spaniards came and on a
Highland Lake
very important lake called Lake Titicaca
it is likely that sailors from Southeast
Asia or from Polynesia reached South
America from the West and brought with
them this technology there doesn't
appear to be any other easy way to do it
back in in the 50s when people thought
of Thor Heyerdahl 's book Contiki that
said that the South Americans went to
Southeast Asia and brought culture
without any explanation of how they ever
could have gotten back because they were
using a square sail now the thinking is
that South America may have been
contacted and affected by cultures from
the West before the Europeans got there
there's also other evidence more having
to do with human skeletons than the more
concrete remains that that South America
was probably reached from Africa before
the Europeans came but again these are
our speculations more than things that
can be firmly pinned down but what is
certainly known is that virtually every
point in the Pacific was reached using
the sailing craft
this spent observation of the heavens
observation of the tides or of the
currents observation of migrating birds
for example in Hawaii it was known that
there must be land somewhere to the east
of Hawaii because there were land birds
that were flying in from the east as
they migrated and landing in Hawaii and
so people in Hawaii could have said well
there must be something over there I
don't know of any North American birds
that you know show up in Spain when they
maybe the Europeans had the same
information I don't know but one of the
really great sagas of world history that
we've had a very hard time recovering in
our narrative forms is a saga of the
peopling of the of the Pacific Ocean and
of Island Southeast Asia and this is one
of the places where you see so clearly
the deficiency of defining history as
being what you can tell from written
documents yes you can take a narrow
definition you can say you know let us
simply postulate that history is what is
recorded in written documents but how
poverty-stricken the story of humankind
would be if we stuck to that not only
does it privileged you know Middle East
China Europe white North America but it
doesn't tell the actual story and some
of the most important and most
interesting stories are the ones that
are coming out of this frontier of work
in archaeology in history of Technology
in history of animal domestication and
more recently in the study of climate
change
and in the study of genetics so for the
for the chapter that deals with these
you know routes of communication where I
wrote the chapter and I felt gee I
should write about real things there is
a Silk Road you've read about there is
indeed ocean commerce that has left a
record and things like the periplus of
the erythraean sea there is some
information about about Africa but the
best stories couldn't go in the book
because they depended to who - to higher
degree upon conjectures drawn from
material or theoretical work and that of
course is a real problem can you do
world history that is solid and free of
conjecture and that will still give you
some sense of what happened in the human
past or do you have to reserve room even
in your textbook form for a more sort of
open-ended and conjectural statement
simply in order to orient the reader as
to you know what may actually have
happened in the past instead of what
shows up in these surviving documents
and that is the end of our sermon for
today drop the dollar in the collection
plate on your way out